should I keep seeing jack Madison's your
ex oh [ __ ]
should I tell her to stop seeing jack
it's fine that you guys hooked up okay
you have my blessing or whatever he's
not my property but she did say it was
fine why did I say it was fine
[Music]
[Music]
all right quickly you need to stop the
excited nervous about her I don't know
how she really feels about all this what
if we have to keep on tiptoeing around
her room I don't think we should keep on
hanging out what am I supposed to do I
really like him I don't know what to do
yeah it's not like she said anything to
me directly but I feel like she's so
pissed at me
I love Bridget she's awesome you do love
Bridget no never mind you can't live
with a crush you have to get over her I
mean she's straight well I don't know
why you're talking to me about it you
should be talking to Madison oh okay
sorry I just need some advice and I
thought that I can talk to you about
this kind of stuff well now it's not a
good time go talk to Madison
[Music]
I just snapped at her and then I walked
off because I don't know I guess I
wanted her to feel something but it's
just like the worst having to listen to
her talk about liking someone else yeah
it sounds terrible ah I just wish it
wasn't seeing him I mean I don't
understand what she's doing like I hate
knowing that there across the hall from
me every night but I don't want to be
petty I mean I don't want to be with him
so why shouldn't she she's your friend
so she should know he's off-limits
yeah I'm gonna talk to her about it
bridge Hey hi Bridget went to the store
she'll be back in a minute okay hey
Maddie hold on I I want to talk to you
look I know this is a weird for you but
you broke up with me remember you said I
wasn't right for you okay yeah but that
doesn't mean you go straight after my
roommate it didn't go straight after
your roommate I met Bridget before
knowing who she was and the same thing
with her she had no idea okay I really
like her and I think she feels the same
way but it's just so difficult with her
always worrying about you all the time
yeah is this something you think you can
try to be okay with you know I don't
know I'll think about it but it's really
hard for me to have you here all the
time
[Music]
hey hey hey um I have to run to class
now but do you want to talk later yeah
yeah I do
[Music]